that is a very very cool award you know
I was supposed to I was supposed to be
the one giving it to you and I was sadly
not able to be there
I'm sorry we didn't get to meet Henry
no white
you tell me what you sound just like my
my son Archie yeah the same little
squeaky voice I love it so tell me are
you and are you a naughty Henry or
you're a good Henry good Eddie you're a
good Henry would you you've just started
school haven't you how about do you know
if I do it how are art and Lily bit
doing they're doing great it answered
your question Henry uh Archie is very
very busy and Lily is uh learning to use
her voice which is great we know what
that's like you have to you have to by
the way you have to continue being the
brave boy that you are okay not just
from not just for your mum and dad but
for your little brother as well you are
a big brother thank you thank you very
much yeah it was uh we were sad not to
meet you but we really appreciate your
time today yeah and um say hi to Megan
for us as well no of course as I said I
would have loved to have seen you guys
in this spend some time with you he
looks like a right character I love it